new developments in the oscar slap scene
and heard round the world as chris rock
was spotted out
that's chris out solo in new york
looking somber as the academy moves up
its board meeting to address possible
consequences for will the new date
friday morning at 9 00 a.m
so why the change well e.t has obtained
this letter to the board of governors
explaining quote following mr smith's
resignation of his academy membership
suspension or expulsion are no longer a
possibility
what are the possible consequences will
could be banned from attending the show
for a certain amount of years they could
also vote to make him ineligible for
future oscars will smith just smack
me
and here's a wild twist turns out any
one of the celebrities at the dolby
theater who witnessed the slap could
have called for a citizen's arrest on
will we spoke this morning to criminal
defense attorney robert hankoff the slap
in question would be considered a
misdemeanor battery in california anyone
who witnesses that can detain someone so
that the police can arrest them the
police would then have authority under
the law to make that arrest it's
unlikely will would get his oscar taken
away but that's exactly what chris
rock's brother is calling for kenny rock
says the slap is hard to watch quote it
eats at me watching it over and over
again because you've seen a loved one
being attacked and there's nothing you
can do about it he also says if chris
knew that jada had alopecia he wouldn't
make a joke about that but he didn't
know
as for will's state of mind heading into
friday's hearing a source tells e.t he
is aware of the backlash that has
surfaced especially from the comedian
community but his close friends are
still privately texting him and trying
to be there for him
okay but this sure can't help jada's 29
year old former lover august alcina
appears to address her affair on a new
single he just dropped well of course
a lot of folks are speculating august's
use of the phrase tangled up is an
obvious reference to this i got into a
different kind of entanglement an
entanglement yes
yes a relationship yes
[Music]
you